this element is unique in the periodic
table element 117 uu s because it's
never been observed in any form at all
on the 5th of April which is just a few
days ago there was a really really quite
key paper accepted into a physics
journal
essentially told us that some folk in
Russia in Dubna had managed to make a
new element here on my computer screen
let's bring up a periodic table so this
is the periodic table as we know it all
of the groups all of the periods right
the way down to number 118 there's only
one element which isn't colored okay so
it doesn't belong to an SP D or F block
hasn't been identified and that's
element number one one seven so this
paper which is published by folk from
the joint Institute for Nuclear Research
in Dubna claimed to have produced a
small number of atoms of element number
117 now though it's really exciting
because it's it's it's the generation of
new matter you know it's almost like a
children's they'll be spying it's like
wow something new something really
exciting it's it's a it's almost akin to
to the announcement of Nobel Prizes and
celebration of good science so yeah it's
a really exciting time the element 117
is a synthetic element what this means
is that it's not stable or it's not
found naturally on the planet okay so
all of the elements with with an atomic
number greater than that of uranium a
non stable they all decay or they they
undergo radioactive decay processes and
one month seven is one of these now if
we want to study the chemistry of any of
these higher or super-heavy elements we
actually have to make them and we have
to make them using linear accelerators
and very very fast accelerator
technologies now you might remember
Martin did a video when he went to the
linear accelerator facility in Germany
and he told us a little bit about an
analogy about how you make these new
atoms or these new elements and his
analogy was really with snow so he made
a snowball and he threw some snow the
snowball at a tree or a target which
already had some snow on it and the lump
of snow on the tree got bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger so what
these guys have done is they've taken a
target which in this case is berkelium
it's a synthetic material which was made
in the United States it took a
tremendous amount of effort to make this
material in itself
that's a completely different story and
they took this berkelium which
incidentally has a half-life of four
somewhere the order of two hundred and
seventy days I think in fact now it's
three hundred and twenty days they had
the half-life of berkelium so these
experiments had to be done pretty
quickly after the berkelium had been
made it was then transferred to the
Russian group who formed a target so a
target is a bit like a CD or a disc it's
nice and flat and circular and it
rotates inside a beam and that beam is
really what the accelerated us because
it takes ions in in this case in the
doubler case in Russia these are calcium
ions so these are calcium twenty with
lots and lots of neutrons so forty-eight
calcium and it shoots a very fast beam
of these ions directly at the target now
they impact and hopefully they undergo
fusion and they generate the new atom or
the new element you might assume that
these experiments might take a very long
period of time and this is true because
the time taken in Dubna was something of
the order of between five and seven
months to prepare just six atoms of this
new material so quite fantastic effort
and a quite fantastic research program
involving world leading scientists from
the Oak Ridge National Laboratories and
also the Dubner laboratories in in in
Russia
well the name of the element well that's
a fantastic question isn't it because
already it has a Latin name unab septum
one one seven okay and this really is a
placeholder in the periodic table so the
process now is that somebody has to
verify these results and once the result
has been verified an open discussion
will be held and that will be moderated
by our you pack the international union
of pure and applied chemistry in the
same way that a new name came up with
copernicium in the past so at the moment
many people especially those in Russia
will start to use Mendeleev's naming
convention for gaps within the periodic
table and Mendeleev would have called
this material iike astatine because
astatine is the
element above it in the periodic table
I'm really not sure who will actually
give the name to this material because
this was a true collaboration between
world-renowned scientists in both the
United States and also in Russia so I
daresay that they'll have a power way
around the table and they'll come up
with a very nice name
this evidence or this this kinetic
evidence is fantastic very very good
supporting evidence for the commonly
held theories of islands of stability
where new elements may well be
discovered with much much higher atomic
mass and these would be over and above
the recognized or the accepted top value
in our table of 118 the new element one
one seven it's an interesting element
and we could perhaps suggest things
about its chemistry by looking at the
periodic table so if we look at the
periodic table we can see that it sits
quite happily in a group which we know
as the halogens so it sits below
fluorine chlorine bromine iodine and
astatine so we know right away that it's
going to want to form an anion it's
going to want to take an extra electron
from an electron donor but what will the
element look like well in its bulk form
I would guess looking at the periodic
table it would be metal or metal oeid
and it would probably be very dark and
lustrous it would be shiny but quite
dark but we have to make more than six